Alex Lieberman is the founder of morning  Brew one of the world's fastest growing  media Brands but morning Brew would have  never been a reality had he not quit his  corporate job at Morgan Stanley and  here's how he made that decision I  thought about things in terms of regret  what would I regret more would I more  regret staying at Morgan Stanley and  seeing someone create effectively their  version of morning brew and it  succeeding or would I more regret  leaving Morgan Stanley doing morning  brew and morning Brew fails and have to  find a new job when I answer that  question which is I would far more  regret staying at Morgan Stanley and  seeing someone succeed with their  version of morning Brew just because  they risked their time when when I  wouldn't